they've said it for years get woke go
broke the woke sexual standards are not
popular just look at old navy
look at what happened to old navy
old navy right now is taking a massive
loss on its company they're angering
lots of customers and why it is being
attributed to their all inclusive sizing
scheme
they they've really bought into the body
positivity movement and now analysts
expect the company to report net sales
3.44 billion dollars down from 3.99
billion dollars in the same period last
year that's a major drop
and this these bad numbers are going to
trigger a management shake up what
changed in the last year did the quality
of their clothes drop no it didn't but i
knew this was going to happen one year
ago i was on the the subway in new york
and i loved love taking the subway and i
especially loved looking at the subway
ads and one of the ads was for old navy
and it was a bunch of
big fat ugly people i'm not it's not
even i'm not even saying that big fat
people can't look good or dress nicely
but this this ad was intentionally
making people look grotesque the point
was to subvert standards of beauty and
they said this is a revolution join the
revolution
something to that effect whatever the
copy on the advertisement was the key to
it was this is a revolution in beauty
standards no it's not i just i go to old
navy so i can buy sweatpants and a
t-shirt i don't go to old navy to engage
in a political revolution but
that was their premise
and they set out to it and they lost a
lot of money as a result it tells you a
couple things
one
it it tells you
that right now
this is not just the radical left
pushing all this craziness that's a
point that i've tried to make to the
right on a number of occasions
capitalism is pushing this stuff too
capitalism is pushing
the revolution everyone wants a
revolution
the left is always pushing for social
revolution in our sexual behaviors in
our traditions in the way we relate to
our country in the way we relate to one
another in the way we relate to our own
human nature and we
revolt even against our biology
but capitalism wants a revolution too
this is this is creative destruction
this is the idea that we're just
constantly going to be in extreme
intense competition with everybody and
everything old is bad and we're going to
innovate and we're going to renovate and
we're going to get rid of all the old
stuff and build bigger and bigger and
cheaper and faster and plastic and it's
going to be better and better and bigger
and you can get it for even less money
and so that that language of revolution
is always there too this was always
one of the real contradictions on the
american right especially during the 90s
and the 2000s
every gop speech
during the 90s and the 2000s and and
even more recently you you get up there
and you say our culture is decaying it's
collapsing it's being ripped apart at
the seams
we need to support traditional standards
and get back to our traditional way of
life and support families and local
communities and all of our traditions
that was the first part of the speech
then the second part of the speech was
and we need creative destruction and we
need to outsource everything and we need
to we need to upend whole communities
and if there's no more job in your
community you've got to move across and
you've got to go work and you've got to
raise gdp and the girls have to go work
and no one should stay at home and raise
the kids and money money money greed is
good
you say wait what happened in the first
part of your speech no no that was just
the first part where i just said a bunch
of stuff to placate the social
conservatives but what i really want is
revolution baby that's what we're doing
and there's always been this tension on
the right
and it's especially become pronounced in
the last 20 or 30 years and what you are
finally seeing you've seen the climax of
revolution revolution revolution
where all of the companies now are even
supporting this
revolution against not just your your
nation not just your local community not
just old standards but but nature itself
a revolution against human biology and
sexuality
and the people i think
are getting sick of revolution
i don't think i'm reading too deeply
into the old navy numbers but even take
old navy aside from it the push back
against disney right now the push back
against state farm the pushback of the
parents movement i think people
people can be swept away in the joy of
revolution
you saw this in the french revolution
the most famous
revolution in modernity
people saying gosh it was this
intoxicating time to be young was very
bliss during the time of the french
revolution but as the french revolution
wore on and the terror came and the
absolute chaos and disorder came people
became disillusioned they pushed back
against it you'll notice a lot of the
young prominent romantic figures in the
early days of the french revolution who
loved it so much the ones who didn't die
young the ones who lived long enough
came to detest the french revolution
they became much more conservative they
said i'm done with the revolution
that is what you're seeing
play out right now among ordinary people
throughout the united states
people are tired
of the revolutions they're tired
of subverted standards of beauty they're
tired of of
constantly hearing this talk
of victimhood and the the total absolute
injustice of every aspect of society
that we need to undo libs of tick tock
are great friends who have who have
exposed a lot of this
they have shown
that apparently
the victimhood pyramid does not merely
exist in terms of race
you know the the darker you are the more
oppressed you are it doesn't merely
exist in terms of sex
you know the gayer transer you are the
more obscure your political or your
sexual identity the more oppressed you
are
there are also gradations of victimhood
within fatness
this is the fatness spectrum a small fat
is a size 18 and lower 1x or 2x i'm a
4x5x i'm a size 26 sometimes 28. i am
the super fat you say i'm speaking over
i am the super fat
that you say i'm speaking over so she's
responding to someone on tiktok and
presumably the person on tiktok is
saying don't you dare speak over someone
who is fatter than you
you shut up you because yes you you
might be fat
you might identify as fat but there's
someone who's fatter and so you need to
shut up
and then this girl responds she says no
i'm super duper fat i'm the fattest girl
there ever was so i'm you shut up i get
to speak over you because i'm the really
fat person but you know what
there is going to be someone fatter than
this lady
i promise you i'd bet money on it go to
some
pacific island somewhere
find some big samoan fella he will be
fatter
now he might rank a little lower because
he's a dude but there will be a big fat
samoan lady and she's going to be bigger
there will or maybe not maybe not
necessarily some
pacific islander but there is someone
there is always someone
who is
more of x y z than you are
that's the end result of all the
victimhood stuff which is by the way why
the left pushes it because if the
premise is
that
victimhood confers virtue
and only the virtuous should speak
and the less virtuous should shut up and
let the virtuous speak
but virtue we're now redefining in this
totally perverted way to mean victimhood
then there's always going to be someone
who is more victimized
so the end result of this is not merely
white people shut up men shut up
straight people shut up
the end result is
everybody shut up everybody shut up
except for the one single most depressed
person in the entire world
i'm glad you like that clip now
stop ring the bell link click subscribe
smash do whatever you have to do get the
notifications head on over to apple
podcast spotify stitch or google play
wherever you get your audio podcasts
leave a 75 star review for the michael
knowles show we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]